executive functions are the mental
processes that enable us to plan focus
attention remember instructions and
juggle multiple tasks successfully we
can distinguish between three components
one working memory two inhibitory
control and three cognitive flexibility
all three are interlinked and influence
each other psychologist Deborah Phillips
from Georgetown University calls it the
air traffic control system of our brain
like an air traffic control system has
to manage lots of airplanes departing
and landing with perfect timing we have
to manage a lot of information and
distractions simultaneously without good
executive functions disaster strikes
[Music]
let's look at the three different
components the working memory is
responsible for processing information
if well developed it allows us to manage
multiple chunks of information at the
same time complex tasks can be solved
and deep ideas understood without much
of it our intelligence is limited
inhibitory control describes our
capability to concentrate regulates our
emotions and controls our behavior
during stressful situations it's an
essential skill if we want to change a
childhood habit without it we might have
trouble controlling our behavior and can
come across as weird cognitive
flexibility is the ability to adapt to
new tasks quickly and to change our
perspective if we have little of it
we can't adapt get stuck in old thoughts
and have tunnel vision we come across as
stubborn and uncooperative
to demonstrate their roles let's compare
two imaginary teenagers Ann and Jay Ann
is a working memory monster she can keep
lots of ideas in her mind at any given
time and mentally buffers digits to
calculate them in her head even if she
gets interrupted or feels a change of
emotions she realizes but is still able
to continue what she started Jays
working memory is tiny what Ann solves
in her head
he has to write down it's hard for him
to read complex sentences or follow a
longer train of thought he gets
distracted easily and starts thinking
about something else at school Ann is an
inhibitory controlled genius she is
fully in charge of her emotions and how
they are expressed in her behavior if a
teacher loses his temper she remains
calm and friendly it's easy for her to
focus for long periods of time as a
result her work is good and a feedback
on it is positive Jai's emotions
instantly express themselves in his
behavior which she often fails to
control he can get distracted easily and
hands he has difficulties finishing what
he started his work remains mediocre
this can lead to negative feedback and a
lower self-esteem Ann's cognitive
flexibility is great she can change her
perspective and find ways around road
blocks at school she adjusts from one
subject to another at the speed of light
Jay has difficulty solving problems
because his thinking is inflexible to
change his perspective in response to
constructive criticism takes a lot of
his mental energy even simple tasks like
switching from talking to listening is
hard for him others can find this
annoying
executive function develops mainly
during the first five years of our lives
a caring playful and nourishing
childhood is our best bet
to increase them free play trains are
inhibitory control and games practice
our working memory playing an instrument
trains our brain to process the notes
and to coordinate the right and left
hand simultaneously if others are
listening we learn to control our
emotions movement is great as well in
football each situation is new ball
possession requires quick decisions and
builds cognitive flexibility one study
showed that kids that walked barefoot
each day for just 16 minutes improve
their working memory because when they
do they need to keep many things in mind
with a lot of practice as kids we become
real executives of our own mind this
then allows us to excel in teams and
help solve some of the world's more
complex problems and since we are able
to focus on them for a long period and
don't give up easily success is just a
matter of time those of you who have
some executive function can now maximize
their learning from this video just turn
off YouTube take out pen and paper and
summarize the concept in your own simple
language if you fail this time try again
and then do it
you
you